Mary here we are once again playing GTA
mods and it is to my understanding that
you have a bunch of mods to show off
they're still coming out there getting
more specific they're getting more
detailed and that's kind of the thing
about the modding community that's so
great so the first one I grabbed was
fuel script gmod point 7 that's by saxes
25 what I like about it is it's just a
simple addition to the car when you get
into any car it will give you a fuel
gauge hmm so if you get in the car
you'll get a little fuel gauge right
above your map there it is so green so
you got about three fourths to the gas
tank and you can refuel your car at a
number of gas stations that are marked
on your map we have one marked right now
we do and we'll go to it but if you do
not get to the gas station on time
before your fuel gauge goes to zero you
your car will stop working damn it and
then I also grabbed one that I really
like I'll show you this now ok this is
customized plate this is version 1.2
point 3 by plastic tangerine and lets me
plastic to change won't wait so it slows
down time yeah conveniently that's the
go-to but and it has what there it is it
gives you about I think eight characters
total so that's the max right there just
enough just enough to get what I wanted
out of it yeah so now that we're at the
gas station if you pull up you have to
sound your horn honks yeah fuel so go
ahead and
very good I'm I'm in a rush oh there it
goes and you're perfectly fueled up and
ready to go tight I like that yeah I
like it's here so what do we have next
the next one I wanted to show you was
when it came out last week but it's
still pretty good i haven't talked about
it yet so this is gravity gun 1.5 and
it's pretty cool you basically use the
stun gun but the mod allows you to use
it as a gravity gun okay so when you hit
oh shoot on your son gun it'll make the
car fly but yes I think it would be more
interesting if we saw what it looked
like if it impacted 70 cows well look
how convenient no cow bowling and see
how this works out yeah go Bessie lives
still good which one's Bessie oh so you
can do uh objects like cows as well oh
wow oh my god yeah does not like this
well I'm i would expect them not to oh
my god get nice and close this truck
drivers not having it your pick up the
truck Oh cause they're both trying to
get through us oh legit okay hey baby so
get your hahahaha get this out of here
mm-hmm see ya we were just tryna home
okay guys just got word from the boss we
gotta move these boxes from this side to
over here hey let's move this okay okay
oh that is so cool whoa so what we gotta
do is move these cows basically what we
got dual is moving out and look there
what I'm up here I know it sounds a
little redundant that's what you said
right thing to do
you take the cows and you put him up
there take the cows you put him up there
dang it look there's one landing you got
it all right dragon he just went only
near look at this he loves you you
really liked heaven again again again
daddy oh oh he didn't say oh that is the
winner that's the winning cow right
there perfect amazing but she is dead oh
god they look awful oh god I want to
play a game it's called can I shoot [ __ ]
I think we can I think we can make this
happen see get him Oh before I think you
gotta shoot earlier I just need him
closer I can't judge distance but he's
so far away all right oh whoa sorry I
have an idea I want Lou this up a little
bit okay yes
you you're the one what a lucky cow
that's it this is it that's all it's
good though that's good okay oh I think
I did something weird well there's a lot
of weird things going on cool oh this is
it don't get scared good oh this is good
this is good i forget there's a rhythm
to it now come on oh look good that one
look good good you're going back up here
oh you ain't doing yet baby oh my God
look at hard forget it dinner is served
well that is charred that is a trophy
kill right there glorious indeed look at
that look like he needs a great look
away physically yeah I did it all right
Rob so I brought you up here with all
our dog companions to show you another
mod that i found i really like it's
called grand theft zombies Oh Oh point
one and this is by gtz devs and all you
do is press f8 and it changes the
environment and then zombies spawn and
try to kill you so it's zaho it's on dog
vs. zombies get him yeah let's get him
boys
come on boys yeah where you make your
yeah stand final stand oh that you see
there that I fell off the edge daddy get
him get him trying to oh oh yeah yeah
yeahs to the streets
oh he's okay he's okay all right Mary
let me go to a skate park here i am now
what is the last mod we got cooking the
last mod i found was called fun vehicles
it's one point 0 by vaughan amigas good
and it's I've only just started messing
with it but you can basically spawn Oh
lots of weird yeah as cars I got this he
can't drop in all the way Oh scared has
got nothing on me um so told art just so
slow I'm so sick the ultimate high yeah
yeah yeah it was good that's better yea
it's going on here we go ribbon back you
know I need a wheelchair I invited the
firemen to come watch me it's because
you're on fire yeah he practices every
day damn it could use some help please
me iphone out of my chair I can't get up
actually whoa whoa roll into the
Cheyenne
now this model are you saying this model
was built for comfort this is like the
rolls-royce right of the cars let's see
help why don't you take it on the street
excuse me can't him delay with you come
on it's so comfy I love you what do you
want to go monkey monkey I want to show
you the best way to have fun that I know
cuz you're my new saw now I want to
teach you don't much yes yes yes I kind
of scooted easy I use it a sidecar
that's invisible I think that's really
modern it's a new feature good luck to
both of you thank you Mary yeah this is
like a roller coaster you can make it oh
I don't know how much longer I can be
cinematic mode Oh hikers oh ok defense
saved your ass oh no monkey hold on ill
billion chip yes billion chip ok i'll
show you the town
he doesn't even look fazed me to the
whole ordeal he must have seen [ __ ] in
his life he's done this ride before oh
you've upset them up I'm sorry set the
monkey monkey I'm sorry to the water
okay but it's your cut flooded the cart
well Rob those are the top mods that i
found this week but until next time see
you here oh no he knew